te has puesto a pensar en qué lugar
pasas la mayor parte de tu vida
les platico que en esta etapa de mi vida
me siento más consciente de mi realidad
es decir soy más selectiva en las cosas
que dedico mi atención y procuro
cuestionar aquello que es diferente a
mis pensamientos pero tengo que admitir
que no siempre ha sido así les voy a
platicar una experiencia personal
por años he tenido la curiosidad de cómo
asimilar la información del cerebro y
por qué llega a afectar las emociones
yo de chiquita era muy sensible con lo
visual me influía considerablemente por
ejemplo las películas cada vez que
pasaban imágenes que me inspiraban me
encontraba a mí misma después de la
película tratando de recrear aquello que
me emociono no obstante cuando veía algo
que me disgustaba o me daban mucho miedo
me ponía a llorar y no podía dejar de
pensar en ello por días o incluso
semanas se me quedaban las imágenes tan
grabadas en mi cabeza que llegaba un
punto en el que me fastidiaba y hasta
las llegaba a confundir con la realidad
les llegó a pasar algo similar ya sea de
niños o inclusive ahora donde no podían
dejar de pensar en algo que les
desagradó que no pudieron controlar que
llegar a sus sentidos pero no sabían qué
hacer para remediarlo
casi puedo escuchar a los adultos
constantemente diciéndome ay natalia
solo es una película o bien
es televisión no es real
esto a mí me molestaba muchísimo me
recuerda mí misma pensando y luego que
tiene que ver me daba exactamente igual
si lo que estaba viendo era ficción al
final de cuentas eran las imágenes las
que causaban un impacto en mi modificado
en mi comportamiento afectando mi
realidad
esa inquietud era algo que yo no lograba
externada a los demás puesto que ni yo
misma lo comprendía eso lo hacía peor
porque pensaba que era la única que se
sentía de esa manera y que estaba
haciendo y racional pero fue justo por
esas situaciones que me empecé a
interesar por los medios de comunicación
pero específicamente quería analizarlos
comprenderlos
tal vez es por esto que algo muy
particular mío es el hecho de que me
gusta ver publicidad o sea soy esa
persona que en vez de cambiarle donde el
programa dice no no no no dejar en los
comerciales
la forma en la que captan mi atención me
impresiona al grado de reflexionar en lo
poderoso que puede llegar a ser la
mercadotecnia dedica una plática de
terry gou doctor y experto en
neuromarketing en el cual hablaba acerca
de un estudio sobre unos consumidores
que influenciaban sus compras en base a
la música de fondo que había pero cuando
les preguntaron si se habían fijado
ellos contestaban que no entre más le
daba vueltas más me identificaba
piénsenlo cuando ustedes van a adquirir
un producto por una publicidad que
vieron no se detienen precisamente a
reflexionar porque el doctor bu me
enseñó con su ejemplo como nuestro
cerebro reacciona estímulos tan sutiles
que ni siquiera nos damos cuenta
ahora pensemos en las grandes compañías
usan pequeños detalles para lograr que
la gente en cuestión de segundos no se
saque la cabeza las ideas de los
productos y no solamente de estos sino
también de la estética de la moraleja de
las cosas que quieren que tú como
cliente te convenzas que son tan reales
que solamente lo que venden puede formar
parte del ideal que se manejan así es
como ellos logran controlar algo tan
personal como lo es una toma de
decisiones primero tienen que asegurarse
de captar tu atención para lograr
permanecer en tu cerebro y
posteriormente influenciar tu acción que
el loco no
suena controlador si se piensa en ello
pero la pregunta es acaso el sector de
la mercadotecnia será el único que
aplique esta técnica
vivimos en una sociedad de consumo de
todo tipo resulta imposible aislarse del
mundo exterior y sus medios
audiovisuales es cada vez más común
recibir información sin pedirlo a veces
sin poder controlarlo cómo hacer para
realmente poner un filtro a un mundo
saturado de mensajes especialmente
cuando estos son desagradables
incluso perturbadores hasta parece
injusto pensar que una vez que te llegan
ya no hay nada que puedas hacer al
respecto porque cómo te sacas de la
cabeza algo que ya entró en tus
pensamientos sin tu consentimiento
previo cuando a mí me llegaba a pasar
sentía impotencia y frustración pero lo
que sucedió un día cambió mi perspectiva
completamente una vez mi mamá y yo
estábamos viendo una serie juntas cuando
de la nada una escena violenta aparece
ella toma el control y le cambia de
canal
sacado de onda yo le pregunté por qué
había hecho eso ella me miró a los ojos
y me dijo todo lo que percibes
automáticamente los registros aunque sea
inconsciente tu cerebro es el que va a
relacionar lo que absorbe con diversas
situaciones emociones y personas en tu
vida cotidiana por eso es muy importante
tomar control de esto alimentando te con
aquello que realmente quieres asociar a
tu personalidad
aquella respuesta de mi mamá a pesar de
que fue inesperada era justo lo que
necesitaba oír para ello sentirme
empoderada respecto a lo que podía tener
influencia sobre mí y eso era todo lo
que consumía osea me refiero a todo
aquello que los sentidos captan tiene un
impacto en nosotros en nuestro ser en
nuestro sentir posteriormente también en
nuestro actuar la universidad de playa
ancha en chile lo mencioné en un
artículo las experiencias que vives
generan imágenes en la mente ya sea
positivas o negativas que luego se
guardan en la memoria que tan
conscientes somos de ello lo habíamos
reflexionado
porque aunque a mí me costó trabajo
analizar y procesar este dato ahora que
lo pienso es como la zona frase eres lo
que comes este dicho implica que lo que
ingieres suelta sus elementos en tu
cuerpo y entre más se consume va
transformando tu organismo lo mismo pasa
con nuestro cerebro no hablamos
solamente de las sustancias que podemos
físicamente ingerir sino de aquello que
va más allá como para impactar lo
psicológico lo mental lo emocional
si se busca que los humanos lleven una
dieta balanceada por qué no poner a
nuestro cerebro a dieta
esta es la parte que más cuesta porque
el mundo no va a cambiar sus contenidos
implica a nosotros cambiar los hábitos
porque tenemos el poder del consumidor
es tu llamado para hacer algo al
respecto
sé que es difícil pero por eso te quiero
compartir 3 estrategias que
personalmente me han funcionado para
tomar control de esto pienso como si se
fuera a construir un edificio
primero bases sólidas define tus
verdaderos valores ojo no lo que quieres
aparentar defender sino aquello que
genuinamente crees que es correcto por
lo que realmente te nace luchar
funcionan como varillas en los cimientos
de un edificio alineando te con tus
virtudes como diría juanes en su
sencillo no creo en él jamás necesito
silencio para poder encontrar mi propia
voz y mi verdad es cierto cuando lo
pienso la respuesta viene inmediatamente
porque todos en el fondo sabemos cuáles
son nuestros valores pero hace falta
admitir los una vez que tenemos nuestra
base bien sólida si queremos que nuestro
edificio sea fuerte hay que hacer el
paso dos demoler lo que nos sirve el
material de construcción barato hay
contenidos que entretienen por un
momento pero que no obstante nos dejan
sintiendo vacíos después
y un edificio vacío se derrumba ante la
más mínima provocación por eso tú mismo
debes estar atento para saber qué cosas
te aportan y que no a veces sirva hacer
un repaso del día a día por ejemplo que
es lo primero que hacemos por la mañana
ver las noticias los programas matutinos
las redes sociales qué es lo que nos
transmite en esas horas nos ayuda a
empezar el día con el pie derecho o más
bien con el izquierdo ahora vayamos a la
escuela al trabajo que ahí es donde a
veces más nos ordenamos qué es lo que
haces para distraerte ver vídeos en
redes ver historias de lo que los demás
se están haciendo eso te da mayor empuje
para trabajar o por el contrario te
desmotiva y hunde más por último antes
de dormir te acuestas viendo la serie
escuchando música redes sociales
todo esto te ayuda a terminar tu día en
paz o te duermes abrumado
para contestar estas preguntas con
sinceridad hace falta tener la fuerza de
un obrero pero no física sino de
voluntad
esto nos lleva al tercer y último paso
de nuestro edificio construir para
crecer me dije a mí misma el chiste es
ser selectivos por ejemplo si estoy
escuchando una canción y esta no expresa
como me quiero sentir mejor la cambio
siempre habrá un ritmo parecido con un
mensaje mejor ahora sí voy a ver una
peli pues checo primero de qué se trata
no vaya a ser que pierda dos horas de mi
tiempo
en la tele si el programa que estoy
viendo es del humor más chafa sin
sentido y que me da risa a cambiarle de
canal
no puedo enfatizar lo mucho que influye
el rating para que un programa se
mantenga al aire entonces a dárselo a
contenidos de calidad en las redes no
dar on me gusta a lo que no gusta si hay
cuentas que no le es la pena ofender con
lo que publican a nosotros tampoco
tendría porqué darnos problemas
reportarlas a y hay que hacerse un favor
no dar solo a quien no seguir es en la
vida real si no a cuentas que realmente
inspiren a mejorar hábitos como dijo el
médico santiago ramón y cajal todo ser
humano puede ser si se lo propone
escultor de su propio cerebro con estas
tres estrategias parece fácil pero qué
pasa cuando lo que nos llama la atención
no nos aporta
para entender la importancia de esto voy
a poner un ejemplo muy actual y
cotidiano pensemos en el género más
popular del momento el reggaetón sus
artistas se encuentran en las listas de
éxitos globales pero específicamente de
méxico y américa latina un instituto
llamado de machos a hombres publicó una
guía que hablaba acerca de este género y
cómo normaliza comportamientos de abusos
estereotipos sociales desigualdad de
género entre otros al ser un medio de
comunicación no podemos negar el poder
cultural que tiene la música por su
capacidad de contar historias y por
tanto reflejar las vivencias de una
sociedad basta con que nos guste el
género con que nos guste el ritmo para
no dejar de repetirla todo el día en
nuestra cabeza si no es que ya la
traemos en el carro y a todo volumen
dicho esto no es muy difícil darse
cuenta que probablemente algún mensaje
de la letra
se debió haber quedado grabado en el
inconsciente verdad el impacto es tal
que hasta se puede ver a niños cantando
esto claro influenciando su desarrollo
porque apenas se encuentran en
descubrimiento de sus valores por eso
tomando en cuenta que su audiencia es
tan amplia que tan grande será el
impacto de lo que promueve de hecho
la frase el que anda con lobos aullar se
enseña nos recuerda que es un problema
colectivo implica que las valores y
costumbres de tu entidad al final llegan
a impactar la manera en la que actúas y
te relacionas con los demás puesto que
al vivir en comunidad compartimos la
responsabilidad de nuestra cultura
ahora habrá gente que dirá ay por cantar
una canción no pasa nada pero por eso si
te pones a cantar algo no te gustaría
estar plenamente consciente de lo que
está diciendo tu boca de este género
escoge la canción que más traigas pegada
en la cabeza y leerla en voz alta sin
ritmo te atreverías a decírselo a
alguien qué pasaría si un día estas
mismas palabras que cantas alguien
llegará y las usará como insulto en tu
contra serías capaz de defenderte
después de haberlo repetido tantas veces
y aparte a vérselas enseñado a tus
amigos
la cosa es no es que la sociedad ignora
que este género sea tan escuchado ni que
su mensaje sea explícito lo que pasa es
que no dimensionamos el impacto real en
la sociedad especialmente en la juventud
tengo que aclarar esto el reggaeton es
sólo un ejemplo pero imagínense si esto
sucede con la música que será con una
infinidad de programas vídeos imágenes
qué es lo que le estará aportando a la
humanidad
no hay que confundirse la moral es
personal el verdadero problema sucede
cuando se defienden supuestos valores
pero se consumen los contrarios así
quien se va a convencer ni siquiera tú
mismo es tan ilógico que hasta podría
dar una teta o que explicando por qué
en pocas palabras es lo que consumes y
en eso te conviertes
por eso más allá de juzgar a los medios
como buenos o malos es importante que
reflexionemos si eso es lo que queremos
reproducir y compartir a los demás
porque puede cambiar tus ideas y valores
inclusive tú misma percepción del mundo
de chiquita me pasó cuando vi aquella
película que no me gustó mi error fue
depender de que los demás comprendieran
y validarán mi sentir pero me di cuenta
que para eso solo te tienes a ti
dicen que cada cabeza es un mundo pero
lo que nadie menciona es que el único
habitante ahí eres tú pasas la mayor
parte de tu vida dentro de tu cabeza haz
que sea un verdadero hogar gracias